[Music]
award season is in full swing people the
Oscars are just around the corner and we
are still reeling over the immensely
difficult choices we had this year could
parasite be the first to take Best
Picture and international feature could
the hangover guy take home Best Director
can we finally get a nomination for
Eddie Murphy is it too late actor Nam
whatever questions you may have we are
here to answer them hello everyone my
name is Mark Ellis and this is the
official Oscar ballot for 2020 bid here
at Rotten Tomatoes so many questions
that we will hopefully answer for you so
then you can make your predictions and
maybe somebody out there can go with the
perfect Oscar ballot 24 for 24 but as we
say around here perfection is not
everything as long as you win that Oscar
pull mom I'm looking right at you I'm
taking the money for the very first time
this year because I have two experts on
my arm this is Jacqueline Kohli this is
Scott mance and I appreciate y'all
taking time out of your busy schedules I
know buck I'll just flew back from
Sundance for this I see pictures of
y'all with the SAG Awards and the
Critics Choice Awards and the Golden
Globes
so Jacqueline why is it that we focus so
much on these other award shows leading
up to the Oscars do they really give us
a tell as to what the Academy is
thinking I mean they do it depends on
the awards show the Golden Globes are
kind of their own magical little
creature and they do exactly what they
want they can have a tendency of
predicting it the Critics Choice Awards
each one of these award shows though
they would hate to admit it the only
reason why they're able to do what they
do is because of the fact that it
relates to the Oscars because the Oscars
is the big show the Oscars don't need
anybody but the Oscars to get people to
care about it so these other awards
shows like to be hand-in-hand whether
they would admit it or not so that
people pay attention to them how they
relate to the Oscars the groups that I
would say are the best predictions WGA
if you're trying to figure out who's
gonna win Best Adapted Best Original the
DGA is like a very like locked on
predictor for Best Director and then the
PGA which is the producers guild for if
you're trying to piss the best Best
Picture last your green book won and
everybody laughed cuz they were like oh
well that's just the producers and then
Romo beat it out this year I'm not gonna
say exactly who my pick is but I'm not
gonna be fooled twice I'm
going with the prognosticators stuff
that tells me that they're probably
gonna win you know for the Directors
Guild all but seven times since 1949 the
winner of Best Director at the DGA went
on to win Best Director at the Oscars
for the producers guilt in the last 30
years 21 winners that the producers
guild went on to win the Oscar for Best
Picture all right so we can look at
these award shows as a predictor or if
you're made absolutely whoever has an
open bar when we look at the actual
Oscars what are the biggest kind of
points of contention for you what's
gonna be the real showdown category this
year the real showdown two of them are
going to be Best Director and Best
Picture I think when it comes to the
acting awards it's kind of a lock you
know we've seen these other award shows
now with the Critics Choice to Golden
Gloves and SAG Awards you know well
we'll get it to when we get into the
details but those four awards are
absolute locks the last award of the
night is gonna be the real nail-biter
we're gonna have to get through 23 other
categories to get there I agree with you
in the sense that that's the category
that people are emotionally invested in
but if we're looking again at these
indicating factors it's also the
category where we kind of know what's
gonna happen we'll get into that later
for me the two categories that I am way
more interested in are the screenplays
because both original screenplay where
we have parasite and Quentin Tarantino
once upon time in Hollywood Hollywood
loves Hollywood and then on the adapted
side you have little women with Greta
Gerwig who's put forth this huge
feminist sort of like I would say
storyline as to why she should be
recognized coming back with her second
film as a Best Picture nominee and you
have Jojo rabbit a divisive film that
Academy members love and I just say that
I think those two categories even though
there's frontrunners in both might be
the most surprising that's one point
less this vid start to threaten the
runtime of the actual Oscars we're gonna
get right into it here's how it's gonna
work we're gonna run through each
category and Scott's gonna give his pick
Jacqueline's gonna give her pick and
we're also gonna hear from you the fans
that's right the incredible editorial
team here at Rotten Tomatoes did a fan
poll they wanted to hear from you and
y'all voted in droves to the tune of
37,000 vote
so for each category I'm gonna let you
know who the fans decided should be the
winner in the case with tiebreaker I'll
make my decision that will be the
deciding factor we're gonna start with
your best supporting category supporting
actress and actor and we're gonna run
through the rest and then close out with
the big four your best lead actress and
actor Best Director and finally Best
Picture Scott I want to get your take on
Best Supporting Actress who's winning it
that's Supporting Actress this is a lot
for me Laura Dern for Merritt story
she's been nominated for Academy Award
two other times for ramblin rose and
Wilde and she has an Emmy for big little
lies but as this divorce attorney
advising Scarlett Johansson she is a
wolf in sheep's clothing
and she stole the movie from from
basically an ensemble cast that
everybody was at the top of their game
she really stood out it's Laura Dern
interesting seeing her on billboards
around town do you agree with the Laura
Dern absolutely also people don't
realize Laura Dern is one of the most
influential members within the Academy
she's on their board of governors which
is sort of like their captains and so I
just would not bet against captain
leading her team to victory Andy if
you're in a theme park in dinosaurs
start there okay this is Laura Dern and
Ray Liotta I want that to be like a
whole show by itself we'll get into my
dream scenario for Netflix next year so
we have Laura Dern and the fans by the
way also say Laura Dern so we're off and
rolling here now as we go to Best
Supporting Actor Jacqueline
have you taken mr. Brad Pitt and there
is not a single woman watching that show
that is gonna be sad about seeing him
walk up onto that stage I actually saw a
description of red Pitt which was
perfect Brad Pitt has the energy of the
freshly single dad walking into a PTA
meeting in a romance movie that is the
vibe that he is taking into 2020 that is
why he's gonna walk home with his second
Oscar its first for acting and really I
think what's one time in Hollywood's
gonna pick up I think at least three
Oscars and I say his is gonna be the
first one of the night and everyone's
gonna be really happy to hear that I'm
predicting two awards for plots upon a
time well we'll get it to those bye
listen as cliff booth it Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood a man who may or may
not have intended to kill his wife
that's a very big a conversational piece
right there
this is sort of like the role he was
born to play
he just exudes coolness he's at the top
of his game and like you mentioned like
Jacqueline mentioned he already does
have an Academy Award but for producing
12 years of slave this is his year yeah
my Brad Pitt workout plan is taking the
cheat day today because I'm having a
glass of champagne and maybe this isn't
my first it fans also said Brad Pitt so
everybody's in agreement this is a nice
very congenial vid so far but now we get
into the screenplays and Scott Jaclyn
foretold that there might be some sort
of controversy or debate when it comes
to screenplay so for original screenplay
let me get your take first and then I go
to Jacqueline who do you have okay for
original screenplay i picking parasite
and here's why first of all I loved Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood and I thought
that Quentin Tarantino's screenplay was
top-notch in very very much him it's a
very personal movie for him but he
already has two Oscars that both of them
are for screenwriting
Pulp Fiction which he shared with Roger
Avery and then Django Unchained so I I
just don't know if they're gonna give
him a third Oscar for screenwriting even
though it is about Hollywood and
Hollywood loves to honor itself fight
bong-soon hos parasite I am of the Bond
hifi mean that was a truly original film
a movie that even we've seen it a few
times like I have the twists and the
turns and the that bonkers wild crazy
moments it is a jaw-dropping film it is
a movie that has a very very important
message where I just don't think that
once upon a time does and your take I'm
going to do a little remembrance when we
sat at this table last year and we said
that Roma was gonna win for Best
Original Screenplay and green book 1 and
the reason why green book 1 is it hit
those Oscar voters where they live this
movie once upon time in Hollywood also
hits them where they live there are
people who want to see Quentin get that
third because that puts him in the class
of Woody Allen as the only two guys that
have won three Best Original Screenplay
Oscar so it's a historic moment he's
only got one more left in the chamber if
you believe what he has to say about yah
yah graffiti my film you're right bong
is a star every single room he walks
into says Quentin Tarantino and I am
actually predicting that Quentin wool if
he wins the WGA this Saturday it's over
which I think he probably will and
I'm not gonna lie to you I think that
parasite is this pretty shiny object
that everybody loves this year but when
they sit down to vote they're gonna vote
with their heart and that movie doesn't
hit them in the heart that way right but
Jacqueline here's the thing so when
we're talking about Best Original
Screenplay and when we get into the
other other awards at the top that we're
going to get into we're parasite and
once upon a time are also nominated you
brought up Green Book and I'm glad you
did because I know I liked the film more
than you did and it did win Screenplay
and it did win Best Picture
but there was a whole lotta backlash to
that movie winning especially Best
Picture yeah so I feel like because the
Academy has doubled its size over the
last few years going from like 4,000 to
almost 9,000 maybe even over 9,000 and
there's more diversity if there's more
gender balance they are younger I think
this is a chance for them to say wait a
minute okay hang on let's really let's
really make a difference here for a
movie that deserves to win and that's
why I think that parasite will prevail
in this category and others agree with
you counterpoint Quentin Tarantino is
one of the most known international
directors and of the diversity that
they've added in those 9,000 members
they have most of them are international
the fans voted with Scott they said
Paris Titans so taking all these
arguments and it's nice to know that the
Academy is a huge Dragon Ball Z fan it's
powers now over 9000 I am also gonna go
with parasite I'm the deciding vote when
there is the tiebreaker so I'm going to
say parasite gonna leave torrents mats
on this one and now we move on to
adapted screenplay so Jacqueline I will
give you the opening salvo for this
category this is definitely gonna be the
same type of situation Greta Gerwig is
immensely popular Little Women is one of
the few films this year does not Center
on any completely male story from the
male point of view it has a female
protagonist I love that film and I think
it's the front-runner right now for a
lot of good reasons however but Jo Jo
rabbit is going to win this one from Mel
Brooks to Patton Oswalt to all of these
very high and influential Academy
members love Jo Jo rabbit and they are
definitely going for that film over
little women well so I'm a big fan of Jo
Jo rabbit I think it is spectacular when
I saw that movie at the Toronto Film
Festival that's Sunday night at the
Princess
Wales Theatre I thought it was a special
film that hearkened back to the
producers it also hearkened back to life
is beautiful Roberto paninis film from
1990 I think 1998 may be 97 I could be
wrong there I'm off by a year but but
here's the thing here's the thing
gretagard wait did not get nominated for
Best Director she should have no women
got nominated for Best Director and I
feel like the fact that she didn't get
nominated for Best Director I feel like
a lot of people in the Academy a lot of
women in the Academy will show their
support for a female writer director I
pushed this film for a screenplay plus
the fact that it deserves to win because
this is a little women for a generation
it is very current it is it feels very
radical and timely for today even though
it takes place you know more than a
hundred years ago I thought it's a
terrific film and I'm going with all
things equal it's it's maybe that makeup
call these things pushes little women
over the top the fans voted for Joker
for Best Adapted Screenplay so who knows
where this category is gonna go
Jacquelyn won the argument for me so I
am gonna side with her and push that
into our ballot and say that Jojo rabbit
is going to win Best adapt and y'all are
tied at one for my it's gonna shock the
world y'all I'm saying you're right
you're absolutely right that you know we
don't have to wait til the top of the
show the screenplay categories will also
be yes I'm fireworks well this one
should go quickly as we move on to
Animated Feature I have a feeling
everybody is on the forky train here ya
know Toy Story 4 no and here's why I
thought about it and you know my heart
says Toy Story 4 because I love the film
and after the first three movies kept
getting better and better
you know Toy Story 3 won the Oscar for
Best Animated Feature for 2010 it was
also nominated nominated for the big one
Best Picture so I just don't think the
Academy is going to give another Toy
Story another Animated Feature it's not
as good at staus Story 3 which I thought
was the best of the three by Toy Story 3
win though Toy Story 3 did win Best
Animated Feature that's why I don't
think that Toy Story 4 will it's also
not as good as toy store what's your
pick for Klaus you're going I'm going
Klaus because it wants 7 any awards
these are the animated Oscars including
Best Animated Feature and
13 times out of the last 18 years the
winner of the Annie for Best Animated
Feature went on to win the Oscar for
Best Animated Feature including last
year's into the spider verse which also
won seven Annie Awards deservedly so the
the fans are saying Toy Story 4 and Tori
4 certainly winning the popularity
contest
with me as well because I got socks
again for Christmas so I'm gonna say Toy
Story 4 is gonna go on the official
ballot I'm not gonna say that animated
feature won't have some surprises but I
thought you were gonna go with missing
link
okay missing leap was another great hit
won the Golden Globe which was a big
surprise but the Golden Globe the
Hollywood Foreign Press you're talking
about 87 members versus nine thousand
yeah different all right now it's all
try to get on the same page with
documentary feature Scott which what
you're looking for this one uh because
Apollo 11 was not nominated major snub
and the directing branch of the Academy
is really kind of Bacher's that movie is
like life itself and won't you be my
neighbor and hoop dreams and what was
the other one three identical strangers
all not nominated and they're all like
masterpiece documentaries so I'm going
with my second favorite which is now the
lead here which is American Factory it
was just so heartbreaking really to
watch and it's a terrific movie yeah I
will just add also to the filmmakers
have been out there they also have a
little bit of the Obama push this is
from the Obamas production company also
kind of like I think a poignant moment
I'm the filmmaker the female filmmaker
of this film she's actually been
battling cancer throughout her Awards
tour and has been braving through it I
saw her at the Oscars lunch and the
other day and she really talks about it
she's like this is no more than what the
people that we were documenting for
three years did and she said you know I
can talk to people in between chemo and
so I think everything totality of the
situation amazing film amazing
filmmakers and a great story for the
season the gans voted for honey land but
American Factory is the one that's going
on the RT ballot as we move on to
international feature film I think I
have a pretty good I'm not usually good
at these things I think I've pretty good
luck on this one
Jacqueline lame is a Rob
[Laughter]
kidding I do love that movie but of
course it's parasite of course I know
wait now wait just a second year just to
stir the conversation stir the pot here
so let's say that parasite gets a big
big big push for best picture and I
think it will more on that soon
what if Academy motor said well we're
gonna give parasite other other big
categories here maybe we should give
foreign film international feature as
it's now being called pain and glory
Pedro almodóvar is a favorite of the
Academy like a few of his films have won
Best International feature when they
recall best foreign film
I think pain and glory is his crowning
achievement it is his masterpiece and
Antonio Banderas did win the Best Actor
prize at the Cannes Film Festival but I
am gonna fit parasite because it's a lot
it's a lot it's a lot and I think you're
giving way too much credit to Academy
voters who spend about five minutes
making these ballots oh you're right and
they usually base it off of things that
they've seen and I love painting a lot
of people yeah we're taking our time
making our valid here you're right I
think you're right I think you know
we're swirl up the night obsessing over
it like really like getting it to it
because we love it but how many County
voters are just like I didn't see this
but yeah that sounds good exactly what
happened to hope more would do so and
I'm sure our fans did a lot of research
as well they also came up with parasite
for theirs
so now we move on to Original Score Oh
Scott man Joker Joker it's it's won one
of two big awards that this movie is
going to win and it is definitely of all
the scores that what's the one that
really really stood out to me I did like
merits story but this was the one for me
yeah
Hilde or don't have to say her last name
but she's female composer which I also
think is really great because I think
there's only been I think a handful of
female composers that have ever even
been nominated for Best Original Score
the other thing that is the best story
about the Joker score it was written
before the film right she wrote the
score based off of the screenplay and
the actors were able to actually listen
to the scoring for the various scenes
while they were shooting which is a
story that not a lot of composers get
that they are normally staring at
post-production footage and scoring to
that so the fact that she was sort of an
impetus and an
raishin for the actors performances and
this is the movie that got the most
nominations it's to me you can see when
you watch that movie the yin and yang of
how the score works with what you're
seeing visually fans also giving Joker
than not we are gonna move on to
Original Song and I thought I caught an
error here for a second Jacqueline
because I saw that you wrote down Rocket
Man and I'm like I don't know a lot
about the movie original song for that
film but it's actually I'm gonna love me
again for the film Rocket Man and that's
what you're taking yeah I'm gonna go
ahead and take Elton John primarily not
because I think it's the best song not
even because I think he did the best
performance you know what I'm leaning on
Elton John has been throwing a post
Oscars party for the better part of
three decades one of the cameras once he
knows more Academy voters than Academy
strategists so I'm gonna go with the guy
that invites people to his party every
single year okay I actually had
something different for Best Original
Song I went what stand-up bye bye
Cynthia Revo for Harriet and I felt like
you know it is a it's a movie that is
it's an essential film and it is a song
for a film that is as timeless and
definitely like I just think it's an
important movie and I just think that
there was certainly not nearly enough
diversity and the nominations across all
the categories and here's a song that is
worthy and its own rights but because
there there should be I feel like there
might be more of a push for for
diversity for the winners that that
could give Cynthia Revo and Harriet and
stand up the edge it's a heck of an
argument you make but Elton John's part
I've been reading about this thing since
I was old enough to worry about the
Oscars in my heart you're right it would
make Cynthia the youngest he got when
her ever after she won an Emmy a Tony
and an Oscar for the color purple and
the live performances around that
however no great argument I hope I hope
right
Elton a coming off that Oscar and he's
gonna be there I mean like again like
he's just he's I think honestly his
comments on the Lion King song is the
reason why it didn't even make it past a
shortlist he's very influential
a voter he's not a bad singer-songwriter
either fans voted for Rocket Man as well
so I'm gonna go with that break that tie
and we move on to the sound mixing and
editing categories will start with sound
editing actually Jacqueline I drove a
Ford Fusion here for this category I
don't know because I don't know if they
want to make those comparisons but board
vs. Ferraris gonna do it some people
versus Ferrari or versus Ferrari that
film definitely puts you in the driver's
seat a lot of it has to do with the
sound mixing and the editing you know
spoiler alert that's my pick for both
and it was also the win at the sound
Awards there's two separate sound Awards
and it wanted both yes god I think I had
the pleasure of seeing you and being a
near company that premiere and we were
just blown away by well that heard okay
first of all Ford first a Ferrari is a
move that should have been nominated for
a whole lot more than it actually was it
was nominated for four Academy Awards
including Best Picture and as a movie
that everyone loves it is made more than
two hundred and thirty million dollars
worldwide a hundred and thirty million
dollars domestic and it is not a
superhero movie it's not a Star Wars
movie it's not a sequel not a prequel
not a reboot not based on a book but it
is based on a true story an American
underdog story and it's a sensational
film it's a fantastic film but yes the
strengths here like you Jacqueline and
sound mixing and sound editing puts you
in the driver's seat the last 30 40
minutes of that movie we're so visceral
and you do not need to be an auto racing
fan to love this film and it is so
visceral that is not just because of the
editing but because of the sound it does
help if you were born near Rockingham
and North Carolina so fans actually
taking 19:17 for this category but we're
sticking with Ford versus Ferrari that
as we get into sound mixing Jacqueline
and Scott also mentioned that they voted
for Ford verse 4 as well fans once again
going 19 17 so you really can't go wrong
either way as far as sound or the
overall quality of the movie but Ford
vs. Ferrari is what we're gonna have on
our ballots so we go to makeup hair
styling and I can't think of a better
expert for that than myself
- Jacqueline on makeup and hair styling
who's taking the prize this one's
actually been a slam dunk
honestly since the first trailer when
Charlize Theron walked out of those
elevator doors eerily looking like megan
kelly just the same way that gary oldman
did when
transform into Winston Churchill and the
team behind that transformation is
nominated again for bombshell it's taken
at home this is one of those locks
that's been a lock for me for a while
absolutely and yeah the darkest hour the
same Kazuhiro won the Academy Award for
that film and to think about about pop
shell is that the the overabundance of
the makeup when you're having roger
ailes by the makeup for Charlize Theron
as megyn kelly is so subtle yeah it's so
much more understated and in some ways
that makes it harder than just burying
John Lithgow under all that makeup and
you're right I remember when I saw the
trailer for bombshell for the first time
and I would want to drop online I went
oh my god oh my god moment is what's
what's gonna make this movie win under
the makeup pretty impressive to pop shot
hands going against y'all once again
there he went with Joker over makeup
hairstyles I can understand it's also
the popularity of Joker in bombshell
that maybe not as many people have been
able to catch that one yet facepaint a
joker is so much more intricate I mean
when you look at Charlize Theron I think
look at me at making Kelly you like like
I really thought it was making Kelly
yeah you know you're standing next to
nicole kidman amore Kelly's kids thought
it was megyn kelly okay you're fooling
the children of the subject this is
pretty remarkable it's pretty good
litmus test and probably deserving of a
tiny gold guy we move on to costume
design so Scott who's taking home the
Oscar for that category I've gone with
little women here just because you know
the Academy they think just love period
pieces and and this this is a period
piece and a half yeah I agree with you
on Little Women it is my pick as of
today but as a spoiler and one that I
don't think should be overlooked is Jo
Jo rabbit because it is a different type
of costume and I actually went to what
they call they have this thing called
like the the bake-off where they bring
in all the crafts people where they
talked about their various different
parts that they use to make things and
making a vibrant colorful version of
Germany in the midst of World War two
was a very difficult task I think I mean
we've we've seen Little Women done
before and they did a lot of cool things
I think with Lori and Timothy's
character with Timothy Xiaomei playing
Lori and Saoirse Ronan playing
Joe but don't be surprised if Joe Joe
rabbit comes out I agree
I was actually torn between the two of
them but again I'm just going for like a
you know the the concentrated push here
for Greta Gerwig because she was snubbed
for Best Director
it's good news for a little women and
it's good news for us here too because
the fans are once again in agreement and
all is well they also voted for little
women as we progress here cinematography
and this is one where even if I had not
seen the certain film that I think you
are gonna vote for I would want it to
win anyway because I'd be voting with my
heart Scott okay Senate ography I mean
look Roger Deakins he already has an
Academy Award that he just went two
years ago overdue a big time for play
for under 20 49 but thank you see
nineteen seventeen you go wow he just
topped himself so for that reason alone
Roger Deakins takes home his second
Academy Award again well deserved very
much so no argument there and the nicest
guy yep super nice guy like the most
humble guy you go up to me you say oh my
god you and the Coen brothers this is
amazing and he's like you know it's just
like you ever have the chance to be with
Jacqueline or Scott one of these award
shows do not leave their son you're
gonna meet a lot interesting people
fans also signing up for nineteen
seventeen next category is production
design Jacqueline which way we lean in
here this one is once upon time in
Hollywood this one actually has been
something which is interesting because
Barbara Lynn who's this is the first
time she's worked with Quentin Tarantino
comes in and basically recreates old
Hollywood in it you know 19 the summer
of 1969 and and and what happened
essentially was Sharon Tate and the
Manson Family that was transformative a
lot of the things that they actually put
into the design of like cliff boots
house and also Rick Dalton's house these
are all like items from Quentin
Tarantino's actual house so like the
whole the whole story feels lived-in and
just between that and the locations
story because that's considered part of
the production design the fact that they
were able to shut down the Hollywood
Freeway for the first time in like 50
years I mentioned on the review of I was
I was one of those cars waiting watching
all the tiny cars I was there for half
an hour and it was a treat because about
15 minutes in I realized
what
was being yeah you go once upon a time
in Hollywood I'm actually I'm changing
my picture I am changing my pic as we
speak oh oh ma know what parasite here
because everything about that film was
created I mean look wait the production
design on Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
is magnificent because of the way they
were created in 1969 in some ways they
had to recreate it in some ways
Hollywood looks just like it did 51
years ago yeah but my god this is 2020
so it's now 51 see what I did there but
but parasite the house in parasite where
most of the action takes place was built
from scratch and the entire neighborhood
the entire city block where the Kim
family lives in that you know below the
the street you know crappy little
apartment all of that was created the
flood was done on this created set and
everything was created and it looked it
looked totally natural so I'm actually
gilma paracin we're going in three
different directions we have once upon a
time parasite fans say 1917 once again
wow I gotta get it towards the
production that I help out by not
driving through it and that would be
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood I get it
I'm gonna say gets the dub you because
you almost lean that way Scott almost
I'm going past it yeah and you might get
a chance to the guys about parasite once
more with our next category film editing
ok film editing I'm gonna go a parasite
on this because first of all you know
there's a scene in the middle of the
film if you haven't seen the movie yet
and shame on you you should see this
film but where the the Kim family is
trying to act get rid of the mate that's
already there and as such a brilliantly
edited scene but the whole movie is
brilliantly edited it did win best
edited dramatic feature at the ACE Eddie
Awards which is an editing award show
and best edit a comedy went to Jo Jo
rabbit but for 22 out of the last 29
years the winner of the ACE edit e a
seddie for best edited drama went on to
win the editing oscar a jacket are we
gonna make it 23 for 30 yeah no
definitely parasite for me as well and
it isn't it is that scene in particular
and also if you look at the linear story
parasites a bit of a longer movie
sometimes a lot of times what ends up
happening with best editing is it's the
most editing that's the reason why the
Irishman was a front-runner for this
when a lot of people's estimation
because of again we you know cutting a
three-hour movie that's obviously a lot
to work yeah three and a half hour movie
that's a lot to work with
but parasite not only shows again it's a
lot of editing but it's very clever it's
very small editing a lot of billable
hours apparently and the fans are also
going with parasites so everybody is in
agreement we put parasite on the docket
moving on we go to the visual effects
category so a lot of movies that had a
lot of stuff that made me believe what
I'm seeing on screen is real so
Jacquelyn what was the most real to you
I know this is like one of those ones
it's probably gonna get me beat up for
it because it is the least like a sexy
movie that people realize but 19:17 is
my pick for this and there's a reason
for 1917 the side-by-side comparisons of
1917 are astounding because you are very
rarely able to tell what they made into
CGI no offense when you see that OHS you
know that it's not really vivid it is
colorful it is lifelike of course but
you can tell it's still CGI with 1917
you are literally looking at this and
they have just more of that remarkable
sort of like slide over of like okay
this is what was here and this is what
wasn't and because of it the fact that
it's a one shot the marriage between the
visual effects team and the
cinematographer and the director and
just locations was a lot there was just
a lot more into that dance that's a
compelling argument against your boy fan
Oh Scott great argument Jacqueline and I
wholeheartedly agree with your your
support of those arguments but I'm going
with Avengers end game here because you
know what the movie is it's the
highest-grossing movie of all time
beating avatar more than 2.9 billion
dollars worldwide it is one of the very
best movies of the year actually fought
over the summer that it had a chance to
actually get nominated for Best Play
yeah I mean I've relied not really kind
of thought that it should have because
it just was such a career capper for the
MCU 22 movies and it was like their
crowning achievement and it's because
that it's the crowning achievement
and the movie works so well it's got to
get something it's gotta get something
and the slam-dunk here it has to go to
visual effects yeah
famous isn't real but he sure looked
real a lot of the stuff in that movie
looked real it is a it is an epic movie
and it's got to get something and what
better a war for it to get then that's
certainly what the fans were thinking
because they also voted for Avengers end
game and so now the tiebreaker goes to
me and I have a tough decision to make
so I'm just gonna say Star Wars the rise
of sky great I'm gonna go Avengers end
game I think I have to vote with my head
not with my heart Avengers money is
Avengers endgame I would never say that
it's not the safe money but the Academy
money is 19:30 real safe money is when
you start to look at your Oscar poll and
you start to see these categories like
documentaries short I didn't see any of
these listen to what Jack Nicole because
she lines up and she's always the first
in line to get to these so documentaries
short subject first of all I want to let
everybody know that currently right now
until the Oscars and for a few weeks
after you can actually go to most
theaters and watch the documentary
live-action and animated shorts in one
block as a film please do it because
these are some really really amazing
stories even though they're short that
being said if you don't want to watch
those and you just want to know what the
frontrunners are and the things I think
will win learning to skateboard a war
zone if you're a girl is amazing it's a
documentary about these Muslim women who
basically come everyday to girls skate
and it's an empowerment story and and
you know these are literally girls
dodging bombs and bullets to come and
have this moment of recreation amazing
live action documentary for short film
I'm gonna go with the neighbors window
I've seen all of these Brotherhood is
the one that a lot of people are leaning
towards right now and I would say that
that's the safe money but neighbors
window if anybody sees that one they
like it and it's got some really great
stars in it I actually think that one
might be the one that could pull it out
so I'm actually going with neighbors
window and then of course animated short
this has been my pick since it was
announced as a Kickstarter in 2017
Matthew Cherry former athlete after the
news with Kobe he was the very first
athlete to win an Academy Award
for deer basketball matthew cherry comes
back in the same category has been
profusely thanking kobe as his
inspiration for doing it it is literally
the best story it's one of the few times
one of these shorts people go up on
stage people are actually gonna want to
listen to the speech because you know
he's gonna talk about kobe so hair love
he's gonna win that one scott so for
those three categories do you have any
actually i picked the same three yeah
and again the only caveat I would say is
Brotherhood is a bit of a safe money but
I have a feeling neighbor's window is
gonna pull it that the fans had
Brotherhood for the for the short film
why but for animated they had hair love
and they also had learning to skateboard
when you're growing a war zone for the
documentary short subject so pretty good
and by the way if you have not seen deer
basketball yet treat yourself wow it's
great we move on to the top four here we
go this is why we show up for these
things it's it's those big awards is
this prestigious it's the speeches it's
a you got to play these people off with
the music because they're thanking so
many people because I have so many
agents it's the lead actors it's the
best director and it's the best picture
of the year so starting with the best
actor in a leading role
Jacqueline Kohli the floor is yours
Joaquin Phoenix is winning and is the
easiest decision I've ever had to make
as far as the lead actor literally
everything is pointing to him winning I
say this but I'm just telling everyone
here right now do not be surprised if we
have an Olivia Colman we sat at this
table last year and we said black
clothes is a lot because literally Glenn
Close won all of the same categories
that Joaquin Phoenix is one leading up
to this she won the SAG she won the
Golden Globes she won the Critics Choice
we all thought it was gonna be Glenn
Close so who is Olivia Colman and Best
Actor this year Adam driver maybe you're
right
Jacqueline Kolya that that decision is
certified fresh in mind I'm just saying
so like I'm gonna bet with what I know
but I know in the back of my heart that
when y'all come to this video later and
be like you were wrong that could be the
reason why okay you're owning Joaquin
Phoenix is a pretty easy selection
the selection there's nothing indicating
that he won't win but that's why I don't
believe it Joaquin Phoenix says this is
his fourth nomination he was nominated
Supporting Actor for gladiator he was
nominated lead actor for walk the line
lead actor for the master so you could
say that he's overdue and while Joker
which mean over a billion dollars
worldwide is a divisive film there's no
question that Joaquin Phoenix gave a
superb like toward the forest
performance yeah but the movie still has
some of its detractors yeah and if
enough of them are in the acting branch
of the Academy I agree with you Adam
driver takes it because let's face it
Merritt story which is a story of
divorce is something that a lot of
Academy voters can't so if there is
going to be an upset in any of the four
acting categories and it could happen
you know what I kind of hope it does
because it does make it for a more
exciting night makes it more interesting
I think that this is the category but
I'll go mo Jack went on here at this one
it's got a people keep a marriage story
versus Joker as a single guy who's a
comedian I don't want to say which one I
relate to more fans also voted for
Joaquin Phoenix as Joker so it's not
maybe not quite a slam-dunk that's why
they play the games but pretty close to
that so Scott let's kick off with you
for Actress in a lead role in a Renee
Zellweger first of all when I saw when I
saw Judy at the Telluride Film Festival
on August 31st at 6:30 p.m. the first
night it was the Friday night right then
and there I said this is the performance
of a lifetime this is an actress who
already has a Supporting Actress Oscar
for 2003's cold mountain but you know
she stepped away from the limelight for
about six or seven ah tears that went
well that's right yeah right Mountain
yeah but for I mean she should have went
for like you know Chicago yeah yeah you
know this this it was just the way she
humanized an iconic figure she does her
own singing her own dancing she's seen
its lie that is not dubbed and it is
such a heartbreaking movie it does not
get it just doesn't go I thought it was
going to get like a manipulative and
over-the-top and melodramatic it does
not do those things it is the
performance of a lifetime the Academy
just went over the rainbow
and I think that the Rene will have them
at hello it's it's an important point
it's a great reference Jacqueline
because again I think one of the things
for this Oscar campaign for Renee
Zellweger is that she did do her own
performances as Judy Garland yeah I
think it's not only the fact that she's
sang and danced but also she has a story
cuz this is the thing Hollywood voters
they don't always see the movie but they
always remember the story the story
behind Judy is some of the same I would
say trials and tribulations that Judy
Garland went through as far as being
beat up by the press being sort of
attacked in ways that she really didn't
have that much control over that is the
same thing that kind of happened with
Renee Zellweger
and so she really related to it she's
very open about the time in her life
when she stepped away from acting and
the reasons why she did it and she said
you know she wanted to give Julie her
moment as a way of also taking back her
own and I think it's a really smart play
for her to be honest about that and
she's been on the awards circuit just
being her lovely Texan and deering self
that is all you really need for her to
walk okay here's the spicy high tech
then because the fans voted for Scarlett
Johansson any chance Scarlett Johansson
is up on that stage it's Lynn
statistically she's got a 20% chance
it's also one of the reasons to tune
into the Oscars in my opinion is to see
if Renee Zellweger is fortunate enough
to win what that speech is like I think
it's going to be a pretty emotional one
so we have two categories left and I
still have a full glass of champagne so
while I take care of that I'm gonna ask
Jacqueline Kohli for Best Director who
you takin yeah I'm like the only one
sipping here which I just want everyone
to know I did this out of love champagne
I'm gonna go with Sam Mendes because
that's what the world says based on what
he's won he won the DGA he won the
Golden Globe he won the Best directing
prize of the Critics Choice even though
it was a tie but he's still won so yeah
it's Sam Mendes and I know that breaks
the bond hives heart it breaks mine too
because I do think if I was being really
honest I think parasites the better
movie but this is the Academy they're
gonna vote for 1917 it hits them right
in the fields Sam's winning a member of
the bong hive self-proclaimed advance
massive huge member I have a bond higher
than my
okay this movie is it is a masterpiece
film it did win the Palme d'Or at the
Cannes Film Festival and if it goes on
to win the Oscar for Best Picture which
we'll get to in a second it will be the
first time since Marti may 1954 that I
think you would think that that happens
a lot now that the best prize at camp
but win the Oscar but it's only happened
you know Marty was you know with the
Ernest Borgnine in his pre McHale's Navy
days or he was the doorman on the single
guy before he was in the black hole I
mean come on he's uh but anyway but
getting back to box but director bong
joon-ho
he made a masterpiece film and I think
that again maybe because of some of the
backlash against the Academy for green
book winning Best Picture that this
could roll over to to support the love
and this is a beloved film everyone
loves parasite I've actually heard
people say and I agree that you know
well 1917 the technique is great with
the seemingly one shot and everything
but emotionally it didn't stay with me
after the movie was over where parasite
did and I couldn't wait to see parasite
again and there's so many like crazy
moments in Paris that you just don't see
them coming and when you see them unfold
you're doing like what the f is going on
here and I just think there is such
massive support he did win the the the
Critics Choice Award Best Director along
with Sam they tied and it's the movie a
parasite one sag dust acting ensemble
not that that translated the best
director but but there is such I feel
like there's that parasite has become a
phenomena there's a groundswell of
support you mentioned in your apartment
you have a bond hive I hope it can
accommodate thousands of people because
the fans also voted for long shooting
party advances house for Best Director
I'm also gonna go with bong for Best
Director so
breaking the time good luck because this
is the deal III I agree with you voting
for your heart says bong joon-ho and I
think in the grand scheme of things it's
the better directing performance but
last year you know what I mean like you
really have to look at the indicative
factors and it's who won the DGA and who
ones this and I think it has a much
better shot at Best Picture than it does
best I thought you brought up last year
Romo went very far last year yeah Roma
won three Academy Awards best foreign
film cinematography Best Director for
Alfonso core on that movie went very
very very far it did not win Best
Picture that of course went the Green
Book but if if Romo just just hear me
out for a second if Roma can go as far
as it did then parasite needs to go
further because it is a better film yeah
but Roma was going up against Green Book
this is not the same as parasite going
up against 1917 and once upon time house
it seems like you're such good panelists
you actually transitioned in the best
picture before well let's let's move it
to best picture and let's have this
conversation because it seems like it is
gonna come down to 1917 versus parasite
it I think those are the two movies so
you know it's weird how once upon a time
just kind of like fell away here I mean
and look because of the preferential
voting system like once upon a time
still has a very very very very strong
key and I think it's a three-person race
once upon time being in there and I love
once upon a time in huh but I really
really do and it's it's actually a film
that I've seen a few times four times
each time I see a lovable you better
think it gets better the second time you
see her and you know it takes a certain
kind of movie and a certain kind of
director to make a film that gets better
the more often you see it thing with
what 1917 is this in 2014 a movie that
had a seemingly one-shot sort of thing
won the Oscar for Best Picture and Best
Director that movie was Birdman which
won over boyhood which I thought boyhood
was the better movie and the more
personally resident movie yes it was but
that's why you know what we did we just
kind of give a Best Picture Oscar to
1917 here's the other thing let's say a
lot of people pick 1917 for their number
one but more people pick parasite as
their
in favorite movie because of the
preferential voting system if more
people have a whole lot of people picked
set parasite as their second favorite
movie of the year
parasite wins yes yes parasite is the
spoiler I'm going with 1979 oh you're
going with parasite right now I will
tell you this if either one of these
scenarios play out I don't think anyone
is going to be particularly sad about it
because they're both brilliant felt
right yeah I completely great look if
1917 winds up perfectly happy and I
won't be happy because I'm on camera
talking about parasite that's so that's
embarrassing and that's an awkward
moment
right like first of all talking with you
about this is thrilling because you know
you've made so many great arguments on
the films that we did differ on that it
makes me second-guess a lot of my picks
but I'm not gonna do it now because I've
already said it but for Best Picture
is a fan vote on your side I will tell
you this between now and Sunday when the
Oscars come out don't be mad when I post
on Twitter a different thing I might go
with Paris I ate because you're right
the preferential ballot is a huge factor
the International factor is a huge
factor and when you have people like
Brad Pitt and Leonardo DiCaprio who are
literally nominated and in one of the
other Best Picture nominated films
raving about parasite it's something to
take note of you really do have to and
it is you're right it is a film that is
loved I would say it's like this it's
the revenant versus spotlight it's lala
land versus moonlight it would be David
defeated Goliath 1917 being the Goliath
but got more than a Christian knew y'all
were gonna do this to me I knew y'all
were gonna split on Best Picture the
most important one and I hi breaker
Esther I am gonna take the one that
involves a year 1917 I figured
title of the year I'm going 1917 for it
I am so appreciative that I have a
front-row seat to y'all's expert
knowledge in the world of the Oscars and
there you have it the rotten tomatoes
Oscar vote for the 2020 ceremony has
been unleashed upon you and whether you
decide to actually go with these picks
or go somewhere else we hope that this
vid if nothing else enlightened you as
you go on your path to either select
with us or make the wrong decisions and
go against us if you guys want to
download the ballot yourself you go to
Rotten Tomatoes comm right now or just
check out the link in this video's
description make sure you subscribe
right here to Rotten Tomatoes and while
you're on this page go ahead and comment
let us know which ones do you think are
locs what is that one that you think is
gonna be the Dark Horse who's pulling
the big upset and what are you gonna do
is all of that oscar pull money once you
win you buy yourself a Tesla you send
your city here your kids to private
school let us know I know what we're
gonna do with it buy another bottle of
champagne for Scott manse and Jacqueline
[Music]
[Music]